hey youtubers is Charlie so earlier this
week I had a day where I did like double
Marvel videos so I thought it'd be fun
to do the same thing for arrow in the
flash today so this is going to be a
breakdown of all the different versions
of the reverse flash or professor zoom
however you want to think about him they
all go by different names but it's
always the same there the Flash's
ultimate enemy and there might be one or
more of them on the flash TV show and
real quick hello any new people if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do flash and arrow videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even doing a special Comic Con
giveaway that'll explain at the end of
this video so the version of the reverse
flash you met first depends on when you
started reading comics or watching the
movies in the TV shows there are at
least five different versions of the
character and another one if you
consider the black flash part of that
lot I will for the purposes of this
video but technically the black flash is
the physical embodiment of death you
know or the negative speed force so it's
not really part of the Thawne lineage so
here's everybody from back to front
front being the new 52 universe there's
the rival from the Golden Age Jay
Garrick days the original professor zoom
ao barred dawn from the late 1960s the
hunter zolomon zoom from Geoff Johns
rebirth era inertia from the late 1990s
and then currently in the new 52
universe the daniel west zoom the black
flash was also created during the 1990s
but subsequent versions of the character
have been used more as like a
counterbalance to the positive flashes
and professor zoom so technically it's
not a villain all their powers are based
on the Speed Force technically hunter
zolomon is a little bit different but
it's all about moving fast through space
and time super fast so you can look at
them all as like a really dysfunctional
Brotherhood of speedsters like a really
terrible fraternity that just Hayes's
the out of you the new TV show
hasn't really given a name to the Speed
Force yet and as of the first episode
Barry Allen has no idea that other
flashes existed before him like Jay
Garrick or will exist in the future so
let's just start with the first one the
first version of the reverse flash was
called the rival his real name was dr.
edward clariss and he was a professor at
the University that Jay Garrick went to
he recreated the chemical accident that
gave Garrick his powers and then called
the formula velocity-9 he started
mass-producing the formula and wearing a
darker version of jay garrick's costume
and committing crimes but the conceit
was is that the formula was
very temporary so eventually he was
caught and thrown in jail in a
subsequent incident klaris ran so fast
that he hit the speed of light and
entered the Speed Force like he became
pure energy Geoff Johns who's a writer
on the TV show right now brought that
character back whenever he was writing
the Justice Society comic in the early
2000s I always forget how Geoff Johns is
really notable for bringing classic
characters back in fact he's the one
that brought barry allen back during the
rebirth comic do not be surprised if you
see a lot of classic heroes and villains
show up on the flash and arrow this
season eventually he turned into pure
speed force again and escaped
so he's floating out there somewhere but
technically he's more of a Jake Garrick
enemy he's not really a Barry Allen
enemy next we have the first zoom
character ale bard Thawne known as
Professor zoom
he was an enemy of the Barry Allen flash
during the Silver Age his character was
the start of tying the reverse flashes
to the good flashes in a blood relative
way it really took the idea of the flash
family to a literal place a bard was
from the 25th century so like four
hundred years from now and the way way
far future
he was the start of this causality time
loop that would become a huge part of
all subsequent flash stories so he
started out as this crazy Barry Allen
fan who at that time had been long dead
so he had plastic surgery to make
himself look like Barry then replicated
the accident that gave him flash powers
found the cosmic treadmill and tried to
go back and meet him in real life just
imagine what his tumblr must have looked
like yikes
so he miscalculated the time travel and
ended up arriving a couple years after
Barry Allen had died he traveled to the
flash museum and learned that he was
destined to become a criminal and as a
result of the stresses of time travel
and learning his true fate he went
completely nuts he tried to pass himself
off as the real Barry Allen until Wally
West beat the crap out of him and sent
him back to the future so then like way
later in the comics they kind of
rebooted the character a little bit but
it still involved a whole lot of time
travel wait wait er he started using the
name professor zoom and kept trying to
go back in time to change the past so
that he could defeat the flash this was
also the start of when the reverse
flashes started trying to kill people in
Barry's family so remember the trailer
for the flash TV show we see a version
of the reverse flash was there when
Barry's mother was being murdered
mild spoiler warnings but I'm guessing a
lot of you already know the plot of
flash rebirth
was published like five years ago so I
don't worry too much about spoilers in
the comments especially for stuff that's
like super super old AO Bart on travel
back so many times and hurt Barry
Allen's family in so many different ways
that finally Barry just snapped his neck
and then retired to the 30th century I
know they're planing a bit fast and
loose with time travel and heroes doing
awful things during a Oberon's era we
also learned that his family descended
from Barry's family
eobard was the descendant of cobalt
blueberries secret twin brother
I know confusing it all happened back in
the comics in the 90s so the doctor who
delivered Barry and his twin brother
also delivered this other woman's baby
named Charlene Thawne he accidentally
killed her baby so he secretly gave her
Barry's twin brother and he was raised
as a Thawne the interesting part about
all this is that on the flash TV show
detective pretty boy is named Edward
Thawne we don't know enough about him
yet but he might secretly be related to
Barry due to some weird time travel
paradox stuff going on TV shows tend to
oversimplify really complicated book
plots hint-hint Game of Thrones so we'll
just have to wait and see how the TV
show deals with their connection the
flash rebirth character brought the a Oh
Bart Thawne character back whenever
Geoff Johns brought Barry Allen back and
at the end of all that they severed
thawne's connection to the Speed Force
and lock him up in iron Heights prison
on the TV show that's the place where
Barry's father is in prison so if they
ever do any prison scenes be on the
lookout for a cell marked Thawne and
thus begins the hunter zolomon zoom era
Zollman was a police officer with Wally
West in Keystone City suliman's area of
expertise was criminology in psychology
so he spent all this time trying to get
inside criminals heads his father was a
serial killer and he had a lot of bad
luck that resulted in his wife leaving
him and getting paralyzed from the waist
down during one of gorilla grodd's
attacks on the city so he had a
legitimately troubled past he was always
a little bit resentful of just being
stuck behind a desk because he was
actually a pretty good police officer
but he always looked up to Wally West
they were good friends he did know that
he was the flash when zolomon asked why
to change his past to reverse the
accident and he refused zolomon tried to
use the cosmic treadmill himself so of
course it went horribly wrong blew up in
his face and severed his connection to
the timestream giving him the ability to
move through time and space he was able
to travel at super speeds just like the
flash
but his powers were not based on the
Speed Force instead he was moving
through times so whenever he talked his
speech would change speeds causing him
to talk to this really funky way as a
result of all that - he also went pretty
insane and concluded that Wally West
refused to help him because he didn't
know real tragedy so Solomon went back
in time to try and kill Wally's pregnant
wife and even though it caused a
miscarriage while he was still able to
stop him by borrowing speed from the
other flashes so this brings up a really
good point the idea that flashes can
grant their powers or their speed to
other flashes making them faster we only
know about Barry Allen on the flash TV
show right now but it's possible if
another flash shows up they can make
Barry faster so the next version of the
reverse flash to exist was inertia he
was a clone of Bart Allen he was
actually a huge part of the Infinite
Crisis and rogues revenge storyline
before the new 52 reboot so he is most
notable for stealing zooms powers and
then getting the Rogues to help him kill
Bart Allen since evil ends up turning on
itself eventually he of course went mad
then killed hunter zolomon then himself
was killed by the Rogues who were taking
revenge for being tricked into killing
Bart Allen so this is where we hit the
new 52 universe and current day right
now the reverse flash is actually Daniel
West the brother of iris West he just
calls himself zoom he got his powers
from a freak accident that granted the
Speed Force to a bunch of people during
an attack from the Rogues
that's also the same event that gave the
Rogues their real life powers on the TV
show we've only met iris West and
detective West so we don't know where
they're going to be doing the Daniell
character it seems like they're just
going to stick with a modified flash
rebirth storyline for inspiration but
expect to see aspects from all the
different versions of the characters for
instance the accident in the new 52
universe that gives all the Rogues their
real-life superpowers that's probably
going to be the particle accelerator
explosion at STAR Labs and I totally
would not be surprised if they combine
the Edward Thawne character the pretty
boy character with hunter zolomon but
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments below which version of the
reverse-flash is your favorite and which
version do you think the show is going
to do I honestly think that they're
actually going to combine multiple
versions of the hunter zolomon character
and the professor zoom character like
there's the one we've seen in the
trailers but that might not necessarily
be Edward Thawne the detective character
at Barry's precinct it can get very
confusing when time travels involved but
I'll get into more spoilers next week
they're actually screening the pilot
episode at Comic Con next week so I'll
do a full review be sure to subscribe to
get that video and if you have seen the
leaked episode please still use spoiler
tags in the comments below because most
people still have not seen it yet here's
the deal with my Flash Comic Con
giveaway I'm going to be giving away a
flash Funko pop figure all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll leave it
open until next week after Comic Con I'm
also going to be recording the arrow and
flash TV panel so I'll be uploading that
footage too they're doing a DC mega
panel after that the Stephen Amell so
staying with applying out some of the
big crossovers the TV shows are doing
between Constantine and Gotham probably
a bunch of Justice League stuff - if you
really want to help me out there is a
voting link in the description it's a
straw poll link that just has all the
different panels that I'm going to be
recording so you can vote on which ones
you want me to upload most in the
meantime click here to learn all about
Robbie Mel's firestorm character and
click here to learn all about that first
episode of arrow season 3 thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you